there's a part in this movie where a
character asked Christian Bale if he is
a policeman and Christian Bale goes do I
look like a cop I couldn't help but
think of this do I look like I had a
little fanboy moment in the theater that
was probably the only one who had that
moment but I had it out of the furnace
is directed by Scott Cooper and stars
Christian Bale Casey Affleck Woody
Harrelson Zoe Saldana Sam Shepard Willem
Dafoe Forest Whitaker incredible cast in
this movie so this movie's plot is
actually fairly straightforward but the
way it's told is a little bit complex
essentially Christian Bale is a steel
mill worker and he is very down-and-out
you know he doesn't seem to have any
luck everything is always going wrong
for this guy he gets involved in a very
bad traffic accident some bad things
happened because of that his brother is
going down the wrong path he's played by
Casey Affleck and he gets involved in
this bare-knuckle boxing ring that's
kind of overseen by Woody Harrelson's
character who's this drug addict and
this psychopath and he's just insane and
because of this really nasty world that
Affleck has surrounded himself around
Christian Bale's character kind of gets
dragged in there as well and then we
have our thrilling dramatic film at
least that's how its billed as a
thriller it's not a thriller it's the
trailer is very deceiving and you know
that happens all the time now whenever I
see a trailer you can kind of tell that
a movie is trying to look more exciting
than it is don't go into this movie
expecting an action movie because you're
going to be disappointed by that because
it's very much so not this is a drama
that is very unconventionally directed
and I think that's kind of a plus for
this movie it has flaws it's definitely
not a perfect movie there are certain
elements to it that could've been a lot
better namely the pacing it takes quite
a while to get to the plot to actually
have the movie start and you're like
okay now I see where this is going but
up until then the performances were so
good that I really didn't mind the slow
plotting Christian Bale is terrific in
this movie he's very good as this guy
because you don't look at him in this
movie and see Patrick Bateman or Bruce
Wayne or Batman you see this guy who's
just this average steel mill worker and
you know he learned how to operate a
furnace in a real steel mill he did all
that work himself and so he's
effortlessly convincing as this normal
guy Casey Affleck gives the best
performance here that I've seen him give
since Gone Baby Gone
he was ex
in this movie as this really tortured
Iraq soldier who's come back after four
tours he's seen a lot of things it's
really really grating on his mind and he
can't figure out a way to live a normal
life woody harrelson steals just about
every scene he's in in this movie he
really chews up the scenery
he was really good as this really nasty
evil person who's just into drugs and
he's a killer he's a psychopath really
in this movie and every scene he was in
you just felt evil radiating from him he
was a great villain I really liked him
in this movie that guy is so versatile
as an actor I just saw him in The Hunger
Games movie where I loved him he was
just like the most likable character as
Haymitch and now he's here and he's just
like the devil and he's very good in
this film another actor who's really
good in this movie who gives one of the
better performances I've seen from him
in a long time is Willem Dafoe it's just
kind of cool to see the Green Goblin and
Batman acting a scene together along
with Zoe Saldana who is a Nabi also the
future Batman's brothers in this movie
I'm really a nerd I mean I apologize the
movie also looks really good Scott
Cooper did a really good job of the
directing of this film it has a very as
I said unconventional way of telling its
story and that is that when you think a
character is going to turn the corner
and fire his gun it doesn't happen that
way you don't get the cliched
reactionary shots and then pull around
the corner and shoot a gun and then pull
back and then pull around and shoot
again you don't get those quick cutting
shots it's all very very subtle and for
that reason I was taken off-guard by
certain parts of this movie sometimes
that was a really strong element to the
film where certain scenes felt very
powerful and sometimes it worked against
the movie where I felt that it was
trying to be something that it didn't
really deserve trying to be a little bit
too metaphorical and have all these
various meanings and hidden messages and
everything and I didn't really feel like
the film script deserve that type of
weight because it really is a very
simple story that just has a very
interesting way of being directed and so
for that reason I was consistently
interested in the film even though it is
a little slow to build the plot at times
Forest Whitaker was also really good in
the movie I mean that was definitely the
strongest point of this film the acting
was phenomenal from everyone involved
with it my major complaint with the film
is kind of strange actually I can't
really say exactly what it is because
it's a spoiler the last shot in the film
feels completely misplaced I have no
idea what it means
I don't know why it's there and it
confuses the hell out of me and it's
been bugging me for a full 24 hours
since I've seen the movie I don't really
understand what it is what it means why
it's there I have looked up things about
it I've talked to other people on IMDB
of everyone's like what does this mean I
don't get it and it sort of put me off
you know because I really like the way
the film concluded and then there's this
shot that's just there and I don't
really know why it's there and it's been
bugging me can't tell you what it is
because it's a spoiler but if you see
the movie you know what I mean
but I still really enjoyed the movie
from an acting and directing perspective
the script could have been a little bit
stronger the plotting could have been a
little bit faster but it's still an
unconventional movie and I think that
that is something that's worth seeing
I'm going to give out of the furnace of
B so guys what's an action film or a
drama or a thriller
that's very unconventional II told that
you liked let me know below in the
comments and as always guys thanks very
much for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes
you